hello everyone I'm Laureen I'm just and
welcome to house of horrors today we're
playing a very special game called never
mind it is currently in alpha I believe
or it's not publicly released but the
lovely Erin Reynolds who is a creative
director of the game got in touch and
she sent over a hot monitor as well so
I'm actually currently wearing it it's
strapped to me it's under my clothing
I'm not going to show you what it looks
like but I am wearing a heart monitor
and apparently this game incorporates
the use of that and the more scared you
get obviously the like your heart rate
increases the harder the game becomes
can you hear us by the way just turned
on my mark are you serious what about
this one is this one exciting is that
yes so this games developed my flying
mosque LLC yeah and yeah hopefully it'll
be interesting out rate monitor funds
funds
we're having some trouble making it work
I know how rate monitor yes I'm hoping
now that I'm here and we're about to
start the stream that it will magically
decide because it can work so we are we
are a I guess scientist for lack of
better words or a doctor at the numerous
algea instance stars yeah so we're than
they called neuro probers yes we are
when you were purpose I mean it's our
job to help usher
our patients onto the path of recovery
by going into their brains and plucking
out memories yes alright so it's
okay as usual let us know how the sound
and whatnot is Wow
look at all the welcome oh my god okay
patients memories manifesting some of
the memories of fun will be real while
others are false manifestations Oh
memories unrelated to their trauma use
the clues in the landscape mindscape
sorry to determine what actually
happened that's interesting once you
have collected all of the photographs
you must select which ones accurately
tell the story of the event and arrange
them in the correct sequence to
reconstruct the events narrative for the
patient all right
so the game also advises that when you
begin to feel stress or anxiety you have
to pause breathe and calm your mind and
actions calm your mind remember the
greatest enemy is simply the one inside
your head oh my god good luck guys
um yeah well apparently the game is
hotter if like you're freaking out you
know it's probably good that the hot
rate limit is not on me pretty we're
short all right so I feel that a forum
cool a forum that's fun I love these
kind of games I'm 26 I'm prior to this I
was a associate editor my address I
don't really need to show you that do i
yeah I understand
nice I'm feeling a very like black may
survive that's cool yeah like that
we are the last hope this is like
eternal sunshine the game yes if you've
just joined us we are playing never mind
a game that also incorporates use of a
bio haptic heartrate monitor a sense of
thing which I am wearing under my
clothes I hope it kicks in have you read
my fancy office this is our office I
think it's our office once there member
they can heal is that how it was
professional bravery is not numbness
reacting as normal recovery huh that's
interesting
calm down it will save the patient and
your life if we do get this heart rate
I'm hoping it always something
ohayo I feel like this could be used for
hassling cars in general yeah oh my god
this should be behind us give you rest
take a mini mental vacation I'm gonna be
taking some mental vacations to some
nice little shops around here ok fine
cool ok so picking up memories we don't
really know if it's working or not yet
so she said make yourself comfortable in
your office right I think can we sit
down I fancied sure
no I don't talk about how dare can we
lie down there now we have so many
chairs a need our help
oh that's freaky alright well I'm going
to go back out then yeah I think that is
where I'm supposed to be going well it's
open
all right let's do this yeah patient age
and a female date of birth fifth wow
she's old December 1966 oh hey I haven't
even read the brief yet come back come
back it's okay it's clean I did I feel
like I need to read the brief before I
go into a patient's mind oh well
is that really quiet for you yes that's
impossible to hear I came here let me
know if you guys can he not at all
otherwise look at the pictures
keeping she loved cats
Eric tase's is this like that JLo movie
movies subtitles here once excited fun
fascias yeah I think I'm good
well you better hear it that's right do
you ever feel like people are just
staring here this is what she's saying
mmm she had a happy childhood and her
dad passed away is it kind of sad
it's the cliff notes should I be taking
notes should I be like yes tell me about
your childhood what the hell is with
that guy's beard face looks like
someone's like a mess painted on yeah
Tia this is a quietest woman in the well
yeah I guess
okay what's happening to you
okay cool we're in the world alright so
the steady key things are back so that
he was so this is where I tried to test
if the house was lucky by standing up
and doing like star drops behind
chessmen
it was fantastic I was having a tea
party
it was so hot that day I remember being
so thirsty ah weird doll party I feel it
we are so small in this game the car oh
yeah that's great
that's what someone's memory looks like
should I test if like the things looking
my doing star jumps again I want to say
yes I suspect it's probably not it's a
shame I replaced the battery on this
movie oh and entry I just take a look
yes we are like three feet oh yeah we do
seems to be a child
ohoho memory where the shortest child in
the world was shortened to the first we
must be like baby hi oh talking
hey my mom and daddy there's that are
you fighting again o HS o yes again no
Santa in the expense book what and a
thousand-piece probably that sounds like
a puzzle everyone today Oh Oh a kitty oh
wait
cinder bikini are fake oh no it's a bit
hard to say that's very strange
oh yay
gang's all here dad is weird because he
was drawn finally hmm looks like there's
no new photographs here so I'm really
hungry I wonder if that will affect my
heartbeat all right let's check
yeah fine I warn me on the history of
the world has knocked on the door while
their mother was showering I'm so tiny
yeah we're so tiny
we're like among the sleep tiny this
kitchen is so bare yeah can I open the
fridge Oh what's this Oh leave your
worries at the door this is home ah like
this is house this is house hmm let's go
up this dark staircase nothing wrong can
happen today memories memories memories
that's why everything's so bad
oh man Delta no I don't know that
horrible link I'm I sit easy the doc you
must kill the light that sucks
well I'm just gonna quickly look around
first oh geez
was there something in there that's
scary no I don't think so mm-hmm
all right let's kill the light that
sucks
that sucks Oh things got Donny
oh bloody hell
hello free keys this reminds me of
Selena okay Serina whatever was oh look
at that
love love love money got milk shower
tree dogs or chicken there is a key
somewhere on the other side of the wall
looks like that might help us that one
gun permit oh god this is gonna go dark
I feel like this is getting oh oh man
daddy showed himself what's everything
he would you like oh cool can we put oh
yeah it's good that's a good idea
that's a good idea
let's have some tea
oh there's what sensitivity I don't know
how I'd feel about traversing in someone
else's memories yeah just free oh yeah
it's a mmm mommy's favorite drink was
growing up grape juice it smelled gross
okay so mommy's a drunken daddy killed
everyone nice alright dude guess out
there Oh what are the what are the other
pictures of those cows that might be a
quick comment and a scary family wedding
portraits alright well I can't Gandhi's
one of them maybe guns all of them yeah
I'll try that the solutions that which
lies solutions can be realized through
that which has been left behind you okay
yeah so it's what's behind us so it's I
like that maybe the gun is the middle
one the first one is something in a
field and the last one is something
about marriage oh love not one last one
so if there's three things this is three
pictures so maybe the middle one is gone
right that's honest milk milk gun love
maybe okay baby
no this yeah tree maybe it's a cow
so can't be surprised if it's not Milt
maybe the lawfulness I think she's
alright yeah yeah she didn't clap in
front of the microphone daddy in his
letters he never wanted to play off to
the mailman brought a new one only
eviction that all guns II oh the doors
opened how's it yeah oh [ __ ] we just
stopped here probably just for safety
narrative baby thanks for joining us in
stream oh god what the hell's going on
here - know what I'm looking forward
I think my heart rate is pretty normal
still nothing's happened just that's
really like freaky
stop yelling everything's fine
there's a letter or girl over there oh
[ __ ] everything got dark in there I
wanted a drink so I tried to pour some
milk I made such a mess I should tell
mom or dad okay
well it's looking that fast that was a
scary room and everything got weird
Wow look at the paintings on the wall
everything's scary down scary
everything got weed all daddy Oh what
have we done Oh daddy puzzle puzzle
pieces on the ground is that my heart
rate that's showing I think so yeah we
should get the puzzle as a puzzle on the
wall well hey they like always turned
away from me to meadow
well that's creepy as [ __ ] don't look at
me
all right I okay so we need to get the
pieces so we can do the puzzle and say
okay oh yeah stop with the corner pieces
that's smart
check em all up are you serious is it
give me hot Oh all right let's gross
yeah looks good to me
yay Oh should we put them on yeah yeah
maybe I should just pick them all up in
one go um oh we could just keep getting
grass pieces like this one that's creepy
oh if you pick them up this up over
there yeah I don't want to stand in
front of I feel like it looks to me of
you bad it's okay they never looky daddy
never looked this I thought he only
cared about his bills not our puzzle
don't do a scary thing
yes I think if I get too close to it
yeah that okay now it's very dark
everything is fine oh it's a corner
piece why is it shaking
maybe my characters getting nervous
can't handle the job
oh nice that doesn't look like it's
going to be a nice puzzle yeah does not
something to the ground didn't I yeah I
did I'd like puzzles puzzles okay okay
almost there
let's hope the world doesn't blow up or
anything else yeah I don't want to hear
screaming again I only got attacked by
all the statues
sweet good puzzling Joe boss
hey the statues are no wait is this a
funeral yeah that thing is looking at me
Jesus kinda killing his wife man see but
don't scream the Omni always wave
goodbye to Daddy when he drove to work
oh stop cook-off you dig I can't see
it's a little like not here we go scab
all right
Nathan what that looks like a place
that'll be good I want to bathe in worse
oh man is about to get more messed up
just right milk oven who is that guy's
wife as burn
anything good Oh what did the sign
change to say is this is home leave your
worries at the door and there's always
two eyes that's nice make it all go away
Oh Teresa Oh lettuce to 1/3
maybe maybe let's check down the side of
the room I'll probably give us a yeah
some clues here rotten apples nice stop
me going upstairs mommy was busy sewing
to find daddy he was usually up there
work I don't think I'm supposed to be
wiggling sausages apples okay well yes
that's that's what it is this is home
leave your worries at the door and I
cotton of milk happy harm milk
everything's home oh ham pour yourself a
cup mmm
maybe it's something see what the cause
of the letters just don't spill me that
would make them hurt themselves yeah
isn't that right why did you spill me
why did you have to make mommy and daddy
so angry I'm sorry
rice okay right tea and milk yeah make
it all go away go away
this is baby oh worries at the door hmm
I don't know good nothing yeah me
neither
I feel like there should be more to say
oh yeah why you try clicking things see
what goes up literally everything yeah
well the word Adam this might be helpful
yeah it looks like there's a pattern or
is it just the way they went out well if
I change the order it's always maybe it
is the color did you get the car well as
yeah actually zing well no that doesn't
work well why would that be well that's
what that's a creepy wood we can smell
yeah people think Tabor uh when they
gave it away what is it
it's bathing was we read before ah
thanks guys clever very clever
oh thanks you clever little ones oh
they're little Wiggly thank you lots and
lots of milk for everyone
what's in it push it doc I'm scared good
thing you're not wearing the thing then
I don't know I'm pretty normal that's
true yeah Oh hug the left wall yeah I
can't good idea oh no only the paint yes
okay it's probably milky right okay all
right
oh [ __ ] oh yeah we milk milk milk follow
the milk I'm stuck I can't move it am i
honest something really yeah there's
like an invisible wall oh [ __ ] what yeah
they're inspired oh I was weird
send up heels we gotta go around to it
yeah yeah it's milk milk milk milk milk
milk super-creepy
let's get milky nope mmm man what kind
of memories this it so messed up it
should be out there somewhere because
that's where the milk is maybe I'll try
a different way maybe I went the wrong
way
seemed like Oh keep on getting killed up
by the way go follow the milk they
whatever these things are just I don't
know what they're something tells me we
don't want to know yeah I definitely
don't
is this it this is where I came from
attendant yeah so we definitely want to
follow it good
I feel like looking at it if they're
dead body is why they moving arey did
end should be that way surely
squeeze through this tiny little gap
maybe it's to do with these I think it's
probably just amazed Oh something
lighting is just tearing me off yeah
also this thing Oh God
can we like girl wood because it pushes
into it pushes into this box and that
has a [ __ ] light over here someone
spilled some milk how be here do you
think it's got to do with me
oh we found it oh we had to get back to
go forward that's very wise just nah put
that on our poster
well bloody milk don't scream or
anything though I liked eating breakfast
alone very sad Shh
what
you know what have you done what have
you done what have you done geez all
right that's good
I'm not gonna touch these this time
around well I think that's done but not
I'm the taster yes all right you know
what I reckon that's gonna be someone
really gruesome like the pet dog or
something got shoved in the oven all
right that's good
I quite like milk I know a lot of people
don't but I do stairs an Oscar father
like the go on this story all right I
bet this is where it's really did he own
okay that ways looked I guess they're
going out again oh look at all the
memories we collected they're doing so
well well we're gonna put him in order
at the end I bet okay yeah I think
that's what it said on the thing is oh
yeah but are we done here like dad tells
me there's something left Oh another
door opened
teacups Oh what the [ __ ] is happening in
there cause weird we is is like enemy we
go oh okay um um they seem to be going
quite fast don't get hit Hey all right
that's probably a good gap I think some
of them are further apart
nothing I can't tell me because they all
right they do look the same all right
here we go first person Frogger don't
don't don't
I mean theme music I know that uh data
oh we can stop in the middle like yeah
like Frogger I think I'm clipping
through the car yeah
kids don't try this on don't try this at
home yeah
housewives does not endorse real-life
Frogger aah you are going read those
thing yeah yeah he died in the car
accident mommy said she was so sad she
hated questions he so did not die in a
car accident
yeah that's why why
why should be why
what's going on
holy crap comeback little picture I
reckon I'm gonna run straight into
something I was suck
this game is trippy man what okay
it's a maze I would just keep hugging
left yeah
be good or this or that
that's a red herring I don't think it is
maybe we follow the sound
no I think the sound could follow the
sound
yeah oh [ __ ]
you serious yeah
I would say keep following the noise
noise puzzle that's old-school
I hear whispers
Diddy daddy
my being led astray
maybe there's more than we did homes
feel like I'm doing
the same time
going
left is it
No
maybe right
what's happening oh oh yeah we did do it
hello yeah follow the sound oh yeah
daddy showed himself we knew that
so you didn't die in a car accident
who's about to get messed up
Oh what the hell man Oh what it was
right that's creepy okay okay so it's a
little truthful eyes it's that face I
want to touch it
there's a light or at least pick up
anything here
yep those eyes are following us yeah
Oh No go away
oh my do I come on man dad or all the
tree changed oh no it didn't
it is the tree in front of the last race
I'm going to go look in that one more
time thank you and knock on the shower
door
no I think I can do anything else here
yes you know the clothes yeah all right
guess it's time to rearrange these
memories okay well I have become the
first one hmm I don't but they have
dates so how do we like arrange alone oh
yeah
no but some of them will be fake
remember how some memories of holes so
we do we only get out the real ones like
the car accident
this would be us stay there I said
month/day/year yeah actually all the
dates to say hey I'm sorry okay alright
okay so I can the Tea Party is real Oh
what she wants oh she wanted to drink
gak she's the last one since she wanted
milk and then mommy was busy well she
was a drink of the right
where's the breakfast want to come in no
that's probably a lie me go I am sitting
on he was busy no I think that happened
right before she found him like that
yeah so drunken the one about what about
him reading the mummy and daddy ones on
the left it seemed like I probably
relevant yeah and then they're going
upstairs fine
oh I can't move any me
okay so doesn't mean so i come soon
maybe the mummy one because we don't
have any evidence for her drinking we
best evidence for him with the letters
unless that was a false memory
daddy newsletters maybe in a milk
well the milk isn't it has to be if well
the tea potty we didn't see anything
either right like there's nothing to
indicate that but it says she was
thirsty which makes sense why she would
want meal okay which is the only reason
I would sink keeping it in anyway it is
just say no kill yeah one it is drink
I think that makes sense what is does it
just like click into place when you're
alright cuz I feel like these are pretty
good gherkin the daddy one in the middle
is replaced with her eating breakfast
alone no but we saw the letters on the
green I know we did but the rest of them
all about her
what happens now game don't just click
the mole until just goes boom oh [ __ ]
oh it's the funeral this is about to get
crazy
yeah just keep walking
oh it's a oh jeez don't give Schrank oh
don't look at me oh come on now
yeah well should we made so much
progress you go shrink
we're sorry I need to get to this
funeral man this Frogger game is
dangerous very much sir these like
phased oh here we go
all right just set wheels
Oh teeka's wait it's a puzzle
okay that's surprising Oh like Tito
steer
um I think I pick it up awesome
so what do I need to make it do
hands oh ah okay oh cool
wait he's not going that's not how
physics yeah yeah we're the best sorry
enough momentum yeah seems like it
the eyes opened okay should we do the
alone yep I'm going okay
maybe I cool oh come on it's alright
there's already one then well then yeah
yeah fine I'll space you out a bit more
- girls many ups thank you for writing
my head like it's a big wheel rolling
I'm getting there nice and easy
okay I think I need one more cup oh no I
think you're okay I think I just need to
be spaced out better cuz like those two
were right next to each other at the top
and then hand upon yeah but see how
there's like none on the left-hand side
cuz like three free hands and left hand
side so if you just face the top left
out like to the left but then these have
a massive space in this way very fast
that you did I think I can take them out
oh no that's a coffin a shape I don't
want to see him staring at us that's
nice
yes all right let's look inside again
did he
oh yeah your old bed sorry daddy
oh he had the gun in his mouth oh [ __ ]
okay that's the picture we need I think
did it go crazy on me
good puzzles
my soundtrack - yeah all right so
I want to kill the middle one I think
it's less relevant to the story of daddy
dying mmm okay I'll change the order of
these two so going upstairs what do you
got a idiom that's my guess oh yes we
got it it was it was a woman a game you
guys definitely kind of he was having
spilled the milk
Oh deal here we go
yeah
and then he shot himself he shot himself
who dear so my mom the story
that sounds healthy
yeah cool Carson was alive this is not
the end of the game this is just our
first patient sweet patient patient one
cure each of us
so I read something that apparently
people who are sleep deprived mm-hmm
more likely to create false memories and
not be able to figure out what's a real
memory and what is a fabricated memory
which freaks me out because I didn't get
very much sleep my life
so that's scary oh wait is that me that
was the first patient done
well it's a credit oh yes okay this is
the game's not complete okay that's cool
yes creepier in the credits the creepy
what is that Louie wants to give me a
hug yeah that was um Oh sad that's
morbid the puzzling is very well done
he's really bust to have another scary
thing no no probably engineer this man
is a cube that's crazy his balls they
said you can have whatever statue you
want I want to be shocked
just make me a shark that's what I said
snake snake
no it's the abyss is that it is it done
oh the cephas any wonder once but
otherwise I would suggest probably so it
seems like this room's gonna fill out as
the game continues to be yeah well I
would say this is all other levels okay
then so I guess that wraps up never bad
unless we've missed something important
that was pretty that's pretty sweet
can I try and leave the place yeah great
I'm out of here I'm gonna go this is too
much for me to handle man that was so
messed up in here
that's how it works a little brushes
sitting down is so hard your vision X
vision X yeah it's pretty sweet
okay yeah so I guess I wrap something
too bad yeah this game is an alpha
mm-hmm so that's never mind which is
available from the website I think it's
never mind the game calm thank you to
Aaron for sending us the game and also
the heart monitor which I'm wearing
right now totally been wearing as usual
let us know what you thought about the
game in the comments below or if you
have any other suggestions for games
that you'd like us to fight or if you're
also an indie developer and you'd like
us to try to game and showcase on the
stream other than that's I'm sorry
I'm Jeff thanks for treating into house
of horrors will be back next week
everyone